[Música]
en nuestra sección de economía hoy como
todas las noches estamos con Jorge
Hurtado Jorge bienvenido Qué tal María
Clara bueno Comencemos con un tema
bastante complicado de entender pero que
usted con seguridad nos explicará la
comisión de bolsa y valores de Estados
Unidos demandó a vainas y también a su
director por malversación de fondos Cómo
es esto Bueno hablamos de la mayor
plataforma de intercambio de
criptomonedas en todo el mundo vainas y
su fundador Champion pensado están
acusados de malversar fondos de
inversores operar como una bolsa no
registrada y también violar varias leyes
de Estados Unidos según este regulador
los 13 cargos son graves algunos como
mezclar los fondos de los clientes
desviarlos a cuentas bajo el control del
fundador falsear las cifras del negocio
y mentir sobre los mecanismos de
seguridad interno según el regulador
estadounidense el exchange que opera
desde 2007 en Estados Unidos ha
ingresado al menos 11.600 millones de
dólares por su actividad en ese país
vainas niega todas las acusaciones la
demanda contra vainas recuerda mucho El
caso de ftx algunas de las acusaciones
incluso a las que se enfrenta binan son
las mismas que enfrenta ftx y su
fundador Sam backman Fred las recientes
presiones regulatorias la crisis
bancaria y también el colapso de ftx
hicieron caer la cuota de mercados de
vainas muchos informes reportan una
tendencia creciente hacia las
alternativas descentralizadas de parte
de los inversores vainas también está
haciendo investigada por el Departamento
de Justicia por un presunto blanqueo de
dinero y violación de sanciones y
sigamos en Estados Unidos porque el país
se acerca a otro récord de exportación
de petróleo Bueno yo va a tener un
impulso muy importante el próximo mes
tras los recortes de producción que
anunció Arabia Saudita los sauditas
anunciaron que reducirían su producción
en torno a un 10% o un millón de
barriles diarios hasta llevarlos a 9
millones de barriles de producción
diario de Julio esto para subir los
precios del petróleo que han caído
debido a las preocupaciones sobre una
posible recesión económica en el mundo
pero son expertos esto podría mejorar
los envíos de Estados Unidos y de
América Latina hacia Europa y Asia en
marzo las exportaciones de petróleo de
Estados Unidos alcanzaron la cifra
récord de 4,5 millones de barriles
diarios por el aumento de compras de
petróleo especialmente de China esto
hizo que la demanda aumentara tras la
noticia el petróleo estadounidense de
referencia y el brenn de referencia
mundial subieron cada uno alrededor de
un dólar por barril bueno Y es que en
medio de los temores de recesión que
usted mencionaba la inflación es un
factor clave y hoy esa inflación tan
alta hizo que el Banco Central de la
eurozona tomara una decisión que va a
afectar a los usuarios de los créditos
El Banco Central europeo advirtió que
las tasas de interés se mantendrán altas
por el tiempo que sea necesario hasta
bajar los precios para los consumidores
eso Sí este reporte nos Lo preparó
nuestro compañero Juan Armando rojas
la difícil batalla contra la carestía en
Europa Aunque la inflación en la
eurozona ha estado bajando desde octubre
del 10% hasta el 6,1% en mayo para las
autoridades económicas sigue siendo un
nivel alto la presidenta del Banco
Central europeo anticipó que las tasas
de interés de los créditos en la
eurozona se mantendrán altas mientras se
logra controlar los altos precios
los últimos datos disponibles sugieren
que los indicadores de las presiones
inflacionarias subyacentes siguen siendo
altos y aunque algunos muestran signos
de moderación no hay evidencia Clara de
que la inflación subyacente ha tocado
techo
en audiencia ante el parlamento europeo
El Banco Central advirtió que todavía
hay un trecho por recorrer en el
propósito de frenar la inflación
nuestras decisiones futuras garantizarán
que las tasas se lleven a niveles lo
suficientemente restrictivos para lograr
un regreso oportuno de la inflación a
Nuestro objetivo de mediano plazo del
2%, y se mantendrán en estos niveles
durante el tiempo que sea necesario
la economía europea se ha visto afectada
por la inflación y tan solo logró crecer
0,1% en el primer trimestre se espera
que el Banco Central vuelva a discutir
un posible ajuste de tasas de interés en
la reunión del próximo 15 de junio Jorge
y esta inflación no solo estaba
afectando a Europa hoy el Primer
Ministro de Israel Benjamin netanyahu
reconoció que los precios al consumidor
en el país son más elevados que en otros
países desarrollados de hecho el
gobierno israelí creó un comité
interministerial para abordar el
problema inflacionario presidido por el
mismo netanyahu el panel incluye a otros
13 ministros netanyahu ya se reunió con
los ministros de finanzas y agricultura
para abrir debates sobre este comité que
se va a centrar en el precio de los
alimentos Israel cerró el 2022 con una
inflación anual del 5,3% fue la más alta
desde el 2008 Israel es El séptimo país
más caro del mundo por delante de Japón
Singapur Hong Kong Canadá o Dinamarca
según la base de datos global numbeo
bueno según eso ya sabemos a dónde
viajar Sería más costoso Sí
definitivamente Gracias Jorge por las
noticias económicas y ustedes continúen
con nosotros Porque continuamos en el
debate